como un paso importante hacia la
justicia así califico vidulfo rosales
abogado de las madres y los padres de
los 43 estudiantes de ayotzinapa la
aprensión de jesús murillo karam quien
fuera procurador general de la república
y a quien se le atribuye la creación de
la llamada verdad histórica que es
rechazada por el actual gobierno en
declaraciones a france 24 vidulfo
rosales dijo que el informe
recientemente presentado sobre el caso
tiene que ir acompañado de acciones
concretas por lo que esta captura parece
ir encaminada en ese sentido no obstante
dijo que estarán muy pendientes del
proceso judicial contra este ex
funcionario de primer nivel del gobierno
de enrique peña nieto- en contraste
alejandro moreno cárdenas dirigente
nacional del partido revolucionario
institucional el partido de jesús
murillo condenó que el gobierno federal
se dedica a perseguir ex funcionarios
que procuraron justicia en lugar de
detener a quienes agredieron y
desaparecieron a los estudiantes de
ayotzinapa fuertemente confrontado con
lópez obrador
moreno dijo que esta aprensión es más un
golpe mediático para desviar la atención
sobre la grave inseguridad que se vive
en el país después de la aprensión de
jesús murillo acusado de los delitos de
tortura desaparición forzada y contra la
administración de justicia
un juez federal libro 83 órdenes de
aprensión incluidas 20 contra mandos
militares y elementos de tropa del
ejército así como 14 contra elementos
del grupo criminal guerreros unidos
jesús murillo se encuentra en el
reclusorio norte donde se desahoga a la
audiencia de su caso